[Musique]
5 juillet en direct de montréal vraiment
directement vers 11h15 heure locale 1
pour que l'instruction et terry à
montréal pour les autres je ne sais pas
alors en france et 80 d'avant sur nous
sur 6,6 blidéen faut s'ajuster à l'été
alors ici en studio on s'est ajusté à
l'été il ya moins de personnes autour de
la table mais heureusement et à autun
personnel du côté de la régie donc sur
lesquels nous dépendons pour la bonne
réalisation technique de cette émission
les voici les voilà pier dutil
marc andré deschamps et benoît durand
bonne main d'applaudissement toujours à
leur poste malgré les vacances
maintenant du côté ici delà de là de
l'autre côté de l'image
il ya évidemment raymond des marteaux
bonjour et mon bonjour bonjour
et puis mathieu les yeux qui est avec
nous pour la première fois bonjour
mathieu bonjour à vous connaissez
comment ça fonctionne cette émission un
peu bizarroïdes punch où j'ai quelques
consignes avance mais sans plus c'est
très flou du coup c'est très flou vous
faites ce que vous voulez et puis le
reste pas important en fait vous ne
connaissez pas le sujet des missions
vous avez peu d'idées de qu'on va parler
aussi au niveau des questions va vous
poser des questions vous ne serez pas la
réponse c'est pas grave l'important
c'est de participer
et puis il ya des points à perdre des
boules à perdre et ça déboule ya une
grosse boule qui est le jeu centrale de
l'émission et bien sûr qu'un éviter un
invité mystère dont on va pas cacher
l'identité dès que l'on va connaître le
sujet des missions que vous allez
devinez avec moi grâce à cette vidéo 5
images on va donner l'identité de cette
et éviter que mondialement connue s'est
invitée elle est reliée à un monde monde
bien particulier
voici l'un disque est donc on parle
aujourd'hui on parle de dos oui va avoir
beaucoup d'eau j'en suis sûr un navire
ou des navires beaucoup les sous-marins
seul humain peut rien vous cacher on va
soul ou peut-être de la guerre au temps
de la guerre ou des conflits du coup oui
sous marins et navires c'est très
descriptif mais encore non j'irai pas
vers les conflits non ça ceux ci
accomplissent avec avec la nature on
parle aussi donc de ça c'est des épaves
des épaves donc de l'exploration de
trésors et déchets sous marin caché dans
le fleuve saint laurent
il y en a un panneau ouais c'est ça je
pense qu'on va d'abord parler des
trésors dans tous les déchets va mieux
des trésors qui pour certains c'est des
déchets pour d'autres les 13 ans alors
voilà c'est c'est un sujet très de 16
ans moi je me suis dit le fleuve saint
laurent
c'est magnifique on ne connaît le fleuve
qu'à sa surface bien souvent alors on va
plonger
on va les voir comment ça se passe avant
d'aller vers notre invité qui est une
spécialiste de la plongée notamment dans
la flotte ce drame qui a plongé bien
d'ailleurs autour du monde
je vais vous proposer notre premier tour
de la grosse boule vous actionnez la
grosse boule c'était comme un failli à
deux boutons
voilà où tout lui montrer un voile à soi
est un deuxième bouton qui fait tourner
dans l'autriche de suspense voilà ça
fonctionne thème aussi vrai un ca à
travailler à bbc
c'est un bon début
alors premier tour de la grosse boule en
affiche la question au grand écran assez
pour vous parler des conflits qui a eu
dans le fassent alors en 1942 c'était la
bataille du fleuve saint laurent
il y avait des sous marins allemands qui
s'y promenaient d'accord et qui attirait
pas sur tout mais qui tirait sur les
convois les bateaux calais ravitailler
les alliés donc je vous rappelle cette
histoire c'est une tranche de l'histoire
canadienne et on retrouve certains de
ces vestiges de bateaux torpillé au
coeur du peut-être pas nécessairement du
classement avant on va vérifier ça dans
quelques instants mais certainement dans
l'estuaire du fleuve saint-laurent egolf
ouais alors voici la question de mai à
octobre 1942 les sous-marins youboat ça
c'est du cheval ont coulé combien de
navires dans l'océan
voici le choix et s à 23 navires b 93
navire où étaient ces cent
soixante-trois navires en jambes et dès
cette semaine
aucun os aucun d'eux aucune de ces
réponses parce que je jouais presque
occulté pour les journées la réponse des
vhu dévoue d'idées donc je sais dire ce
que je traîne alors mathieu je dirais 93
navire 93 maneri en plein milieu a été
un bon tireur sur les bateaux oui
vraiment 23 23
c'est pourquoi si peu
c'est pas parce que vous me connaissez
vous et maintenant on va afficher la
bonne réponse devant un miroir on
regarde les étoiles vont apparaître à
domicile les torpilles
dans un instant ou deux ça prend du
temps avec la torpille se rendent sur
les flancs du navire comme vous le savez
23 navires voilà tout chez moi vraiment
200 personnes qui ont perdu la vie dans
cet ordre urgent là on a beaucoup parlé
de ça alors que bond 23 navires ça me
semble relativement peu en comparaison
de ce qui a pu se passer ailleurs
mais retrouver des allemands comme ça à
notre porte
c'est quand même assez étonnant ça a dû
choquer beaucoup de gens parce que vous
avez une histoire de raconter là dessus
chez vous connaissez beaucoup de gens
vraiment c'est que au niveau familial
mon père fait la bataille de
l'atlantique pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et les convois de russie et on
à gc médailles dans la maison ah ouais
préfet et on a beaucoup parlé de ces de
ces mouvements là on lui des images
également de prises par des sous
mariniers allemands de la ville de new
york notamment
il naviguait au large de new york est
il était non détectées rien et dans
l'estuaire du saint-laurent
effectivement ils sont rendus facilement
assez loin la presse que j'irais pas
dire jusqu'à l'île d'orléans mais
facilement les locaux on va parler de
tout ça avec notre expert en plongée
sous marine la voici la voilà sur skype
il s'agit de nathalie lasselin bonjour
madame la semaine bonjour commenté où ça
va très bien radio-canada a eu plaisir
au cours des dernières années de faire
des reportages avez-vous notamment lors
d'une plongée extraordinaire je pense
que c'était l'an dernier au coeur
pratiquement montréal j'ai été les voir
à quoi ça ressemblait le sous sol afin
que je suis le sudoku jours et ça c'est
aux portes de la ville là où il ya un
million et demi de citoyens qui sont sur
le trottoir vous vous étiez de l'autre
côté et nous on n'a pas pu filmer j'ai
pas vu d'image on a vu des images de
vous vous préparez à la plongée mais je
n'ai jamais vraiment su ce que vous avez
vu à quoi ça ressemble en ce moment par
exemple au parc de montréal
alors en fait effectivement il ya un peu
d'image qui ont été montrées parce que
lorsque je faisais la plongée j'étais
tout seul dans l'eau excepté pour des
ravitaillements dont peu digne de
plongée à montréal c'est pas nous avons
une plongée où on voit des choses même
on expérimente des choses et c'est là où
c'est très intéressant en fait d'avoir
la subtilité et la richesse de passe
alors à la visibilité à montréal divers
en et échange énormément mais est
rarement meilleur que cette digue et au
maximum sinon la plupart de temps on va
avoir trois pieds 4 et 5 est par contre
tout au long de la traversée que j'ai
fait de l'île perrot jusqu à repentigny
donc à peu près seul un peu plus de 70
km on rencontre un fleuve qui est
extrêmement changeant avec des eaux faut
des courants très intense et ce fleuve
là elle peuplée de plus de 73 espèces de
poissons là en ce moment au monde des
images d'autres expéditions que vous
avez effectués notamment en arctique
vous étiez un article il ya quelques
semaines à peine et vous ne pouvez pas
communiquer avec vous il n'ya pas le 5 g
là bas qu'il se dommage non
au large d'une ville qui s'appelle
arctique mais qui pour la première fois
de l'avenir ont eu un intérêt l'internet
et le téléphone cellulaire en fait
quelques jours avant que je parte donc
j'ai passé un mois sur la banquise temps
communication si ce n'est le téléphone
satellite pour les urgences et la raison
de ma mission là bas était de soutenir
une équipe de tournage pour national
geographic qui essaient de documenter
les narvals et les bélougas il leur
arrive elle est finalement ce qu'on a
surtout remarqué c'est que les
changements climatiques nous ont donné
beaucoup de fil à retordre dans les 28
jours pendant passé sur la banquise
on a eu plus de dix jours de pluie
c'était quelque chose d'absolument
nouveau pour moi
dans les deux dernières années il ya un
petit peu plus de pluie en articles mais
au mois de juin et quelque chose de
complètement inhabituelles écoutez je
sais que vous êtes vous recevez du
continent et c'est facile de faire des
compliments vous êtes une femme
exceptionnelle vous faites quelque chose
de remarquable au niveau de la bravoure
sa demande mardi que du courage de
descendre dans des par exemple même au
large de montréal dans ces courants
marins il ya les rapides et c'est pas si
vous êtes une exploratrice en quelque
sorte c'est pas tout le monde qui sait
comment se débrouiller dans ces énoncés
dans ces eaux là il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui sont nécessairement passer
par des coins vous êtes passé non
effectivement j'ai eu à gérer la chance
et l'opportunité de plonger dans des en
gros personne avait mis les pieds en ce
moment certaines grottes au mexique -
chine ou même congés dans les rapides à
montréal
je pourrais très amusant en fait du
projet de montréal de ces aubaines
apathique
c'était de monter un projet d'expédition
extrême la 20 minutes du centre-ville et
pourquoi c'est simplement de dire vous
savez pas besoin d'aller à l'autre bout
du monde finalement mais chez nous il ya
encore plein de choses à découvrir sans
extraordinaire c'est sûr que oui je me
définis un peu comme une exploratrice
des temps modernes avec des outils
différents un territoire un peu
différent c'est de l' aventure documenté
donc c'est ça pour moi l'exploration pur
c'est d'essayer d'aller voir ici cash
qu'on ne connaît pas encore et de le
partager aux aux plus grandes maintenant
même costaud s'il ya déjà qu'il ya des
questions pour vous alors on les écoute
on y va qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que baic
est ce que vous cherchiez dans le saint
laurent
alors on s'est tiré plusieurs étapes à
ce projet là départ c'est parti d'une
curiosité parce que chaque fois je
revenais au real je le disais ouais
c'est bien d'aller partout dans le monde
mais je ne sais même pas ce qui se passe
dans le saint-laurent à montréal
donc j'avais envie d'y aller par
curiosité et assez rapidement en fait il
ya d'autres éléments qui sont venus
jouer en ligne de compte notamment les
contaminants émergents ce qu'on appelle
les contaminants d'intérêt émergents
pesticides herbicides atrazine résidus
de médicaments et caetera et j'ai
collaboré avec l'université de montréal
avec le département de chimie pour faire
des analyses d'europe porte en ontario
jusqu'à trois-rivières donc sur 350
kilomètres pour aller faire des
prélèvements d'eau et sédiments et devra
effectivement est ce qu'on trouve des
traces de ces contaminants là et ce
qu'on voit s'en ait été ou non donc sa
7ème à mon projet je risque entité et
parallèlement à cela et comme tous les
cours d'eau du monde et énormément de
pollution et j'ai envie avec des amis
plongeurs de faire de donner mon coup de
main donc on a fait des campagnes de
nettoyage dans le fleuve saint laurent
dans des endroits où on va pas plonger
mais qui sont utilisés par les montréal
et les gens de la banlieue
quand vous avez fait cette exploration
je vous ai interviewé à l'époque j'avais
fait un dossier sur radio canada
international sur cette promenade sous
marine montréalais ge et je vous avais
posé la question aussi avec la boutade
comment est ce que vous avez plongé dans
ce métier pendant j'ai plongé dans ce
métier vous direz c'est la vie qui m'a
rattrapé un petit peu quand j'étais
petit quand j'étais enfant je voulais
être spéléologues
mais bon ce n'était pas vraiment un
métier c'était pas vraiment un métier
pour les femmes et je laissais tomber ça
pendant des années jusqu'au jour où j'ai
commencé à faire de la plongée spéléo
notamment aux états unis est
tranquillement en tête tous les revenus
et je me suis posé la question de ce qui
était vraiment ma passion et ce au jeu
voulait dédier ma vie et voilà je me
suis mis à faire de la plongée
sous-marine et pour moi au bout de
quelques plongées ans j'ai eu une bonne
flottabilité ça n'avait pas de sens jeu
plongée pour le plaisir je voulais
apporter une calepin j'étais déjà
caméraman à l'époque by loeb
non j'ai commencé à faire des films des
documentaires pour ramener un maximum
d'image d'endroits où peu de gens
finalement l'opportunité dhabi alors je
suis assez lent des plongées confortable
des mers du sud
je pense que je garde ça pour mes vieux
jours pour l'instant je préfère me
mesurer entre guillemets éléments et de
voir dans ces endroits dans ces milieux
pauvres
pense-t-il s potentiellement on peut
trouver le saint laurent était mon
terrain de jeu d'enfant sont faites les
îles de boucherville moi c'est ça c'est
chez moi c'est là où j'ai grandi et j'ai
passé j'ai plus trop combien d'été sur
ces îles d'aptitude cela dit on nous
disait à chaque fois
n'allez pas dans l'eau c'est polluer
quand vous rentrez c'était la douche
ensuite comment se prépare-t-on à faire
cette expédition au niveau de son corps
pour se protéger de tous ces polluants
dans le fleuve
c'est surtout la première des
problématiques stèles et au 2 e coli
sont présents allez je croisais pas
vraiment qu'il ne pleuve pas ni les
jours passés dans l'expédition mis la
journée de l'expédition
parce qu mathy automatiquement les
villes autour du fleuve saint-laurent ne
peuvent pas gérer toutes les quantités
donc sont rejetées dans le fleuve dont
une partie qui va directement dans le
fonds en traitement et ce à chaque jour
de grande pluie à la grandeur de l'île
de montréal c'est un peu la même
situation on n'a malheureusement pas les
infrastructures pour ça alors sachant ça
c'est sûr que je me suis équipé d'un une
combinaison complètement et ange les
gants et étanche et un masque intégral a
fool ce risque faisant en sorte que
l'eau était minimalement en contact avec
ma peau excepté lorsque je devais manger
et c'est sûr que les endroits à l'est
des îles de boucherville et l'île aux
vaches de montréal
l'annoncé que les panaches d'eaux usées
aussi bien la rive sud de montréal se
déverse dans cette voie là j'avais un
petit peu mon envie de manger c'est ce
pur je me protégeais un peu plus fois
l'odm avait à matthew
avez une question allez-y on voit à
l'écran la des différents objets que
vous allez remonter du fond du saint
laurent
qu'est ce qu'elle est l'objet le plus
atypique que vous avez trouvé au fond il
ya une drôle d'histoire je suis de
résumer très vite mais à un moment donné
on a on a remonté une petite statue
ailes d'un ange en poterie assez brune
assez vintage des années 60 et au même
moment il ya une femme qui jeter des
fleurs au fleuve saint-laurent mémoire à
son mari qui étaient des femmes et cet
objet l'a finalement on lui a remis un
petit peu en mémoire elle à son mari qui
était décédé quelques années plus tôt
alors c'était des choses assez
particulière c'est ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimée de ses campagnes là c'est que ça
nous permet de parler avec les gens qui
se promènent et de la de les
conscientiser un petit peu un tout ce
qu'on jette
consciemment ou inconsciemment que ce
soit dans nos toilettes dans nos écrits
ou dans la rue ultime on va se retrouver
dans le fleuve elle ne va pas
disparaître alors dans ce qu'on a
retrouvé là il y avait une voiture des
motos des vélos une boîte pour collecter
l'argent dans un autobus un appareil
photo dessin terrain probablement volé
la quantité de choses on pourrait ouvrir
un musée parfois musée des horreurs mais
c'est assez varié ce qu'on peut trouver
dans l'eau parlant de musée bien sûr
j'aimerais vous amener maintenant sur la
piste historique que des naufrages y en
a eu un certain nombre
on va en parler plus tard à l'émission
mais je sais que vous vous avez
certainement une expérience plus
personnelle de certains navires qui ont
sombré dans le fleuve saint laurent
parce qu'à chaque fois que nous on fait
un article sur un la découverte d'un
nouveau navire quelque chose le long du
fleuve saint-laurent ça au niveau des
décors
comment ils appellent ça un langage web
le nombre de huit objectifs publics en
français nombre de clics là est
épouvantable les gens sont très très
curieux par rapport à ce qu'ils ne
voient pas et qu'ils aimeraient il ya
comme ça c'est vraiment un mystère c'est
comme phares automatique comme histoire
qu'est ce que vous avez vécu dans le
fleuve saint laurent au niveau des de
ces vieux bâtiments navires qu'ils
n'avaient pas merci pour le terme géré m
et pas même des épars qu'on peut
considérer luminar ont une histoire
ce que j'adore et gars que j'ai plongé
où j'étais la première avec mon copain a
plongé pour l'aciérie chasseurs départ
qui s'appelle le city of québec
il était à un bateau qui avait été
utilisé pendant la guerre de sécession
un navire qui au large de l'île verte
qui est relativement intact dans des
eaux très froides avec une visibilité
centenaire et de plonger cette épave en
fait on a une fenêtre entre les marais à
peu près une vingtaine de minutes donc
il ya un défi sportif est un défi
logistique et le moment où on descend
sur la corde et on arrive sur cette
épave là guy rouveyre dont on voit la
brèche on en voit encore les roues à
aubes et c'est de la magie n'est ni plus
ni moins de la magie est là on fait
appel à notre coeur d'enfant on se dit
on aime toujours trouver des trésors et
là c'est un trésor a absolument
extraordinaire qu'on trouve
et voilà on a juste 20 minutes pour en
profiter on envie de toujours y
retourner et à chaque fois quand on
remonte du nid de ces épaves là c'est
toujours de seulement des copies de
compter son emploi est retourné la
prochaine fois donc ça a été une
aventure extraordinaire
parfois le fleuve saint laurent nous
donne aussi un petit peu du fil à
retordre en a plongé une épave au large
de l'île aux coudres le avons une fois
de plus ont été les premiers à plonger
là et on a été entre guillemets victimes
de ce qu'on appelle des valves
sous-marines
donc c'est un phénomène qui est étudiée
par l'université de rimouski est en fait
parce qu'il ya de l'eau saline de l'eau
douce
il sent from à la profondeur ça fait 2
par la différence de salinité de
température des vagues soigne et en fait
c'est vague là ont ni plus ni moins
coucher complètement l'horizontale notre
ligne nous amener à la surface avec les
trois bouées et on s'est retrouvé en
quelques secondes à 60 qui louent les
chars fois il ya une demande toute la
mouture d'essayer de pouvoir trouver ces
épaves là de pouvoir les plongées très
souvent c'est un petit peu comme pour
les la plongée spéléo les grottes ont
fait énormément de tentatives avant
d'avoir une tentative qui est couronnée
de succès où on trouve vraiment quelque
chose d'intéressant
alors il ya tout cet aspect là parfois
évidemment il ya les artefacts qui sont
protégés par le receveur des épaves
nada est également il ya une histoire
humaine en arrière de ces épaves là il
ya une dizaine d'années j'ai fait un
documentaire sur un départ qui s'appelle
le dit vikings qui était la plus grosse
barge de forage et de dynamitage entre
le long de la voie maritime du
saint-laurent et l époque effet le film
est resté un survivant en fait sur les
50 un petit travail et là il en est
resté 11 après l'explosion et lui était
le dernier et d'avoir ce vieux monsieur
me partager son histoire avec tant de
passion et cet attachement remise
d'alors votre attachement aux hyper
ville le fleuve saint-laurent lorsqu'on
commence à le côtoyer lorsqu'on pense à
se rapprocher de lui à la surface ou
sous l'eau on y devient foncièrement
attaché et il ya une relation ses cinq
sens et une relation du talent c'est
aussi notre source d'eau potable et on
développe cette relation-là qui devient
une relation passionnée automatiquement
nathalie on a une excellente relation
avec nos régies quand vous le savez et
on lance des défis à chaque semaine ils
ont deux défis à remplir aujourd'hui le
premier défi c'est de nous amener tous
ensemble sur votre site web qui
s'appelle nathalie lasselin points comme
pour partir la conversation avec nos
internautes pour qu'ils poursuivent leur
découverte de ce que vous faites au
niveau 2 de ce que vous filmez parce qu
on a montré quelques vidéos il ya
beaucoup de choses se ruent mais oh et
puis aussi les intéressés au fait que
vous avez une pendant qu'on regarde donc
votre site web vous avez vous gagnez
votre vie parce que vous gagnez des sous
ça coûte cher ce que vous faites vous
gagnez votre vie également je pense
comme vous avez un club de plongée
qu'est ce que vous faites exactement au
niveau professionnel pour aider d'autres
à découvrir comment faire les choses de
manière sécuritaire on peut faire la
plonge et mais effectivement aussi donc
elles m'ont tellement exploratrice
nessma mais à un moment donné les gens
demandez mais est-ce que tu donnes des
formations de plongée et finalement jugé
ben non et je suis allé me former pour
pouvoir donner des formations de plonger
une déformation davantage avancé donc
des gens qui veulent plonger avec des
mélanges qu'on appelle trimix des
grandes profondeurs où des gens qui
veulent plonger en recycleur le reste
classé la machine que vous voyez sur mon
dos à l'écran pour le moment et aussi
des jeunes qui veulent aller faire de la
plongée spéléo donc je les amène plonger
un petit peu partout à l'étranger et je
les forme pour qu'ils soient en mesure
de devenir des plongeurs extrêmement
bien équipée expérimentés et toujours
avec un regard critique sur ce qu'il
faut personne n'est à l'abri d'un
incident ou d'un accident il pour moi
c'est extrêmement important de mettre en
lumière toute cette préparation là le
regarder toutes les choses qui peuvent
nous arriver et se dire je ne ferai pas
partie des steppes de remonter à la
surface sains et saufs
j'ai une question ici qui vient de la
régir puisqu'on a décidé d impliquer ils
veulent continuer le jeu
alors voici une question qui concerne la
longévité c'est un peu sérieux l'adjoint
de la longévité des plongeurs
apparemment il y aurait un impact sur le
fait de plonger souvent sur sur la santé
d'une personne
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce qu'on sait
à ce sujet là maintenant il ya
différentes études qui ont été faits
notamment par dan qui est d'eyl à la
tenait toile ceci dit le type de plongée
et un plongeur peuvent faire est
extrêmement varié d'une personne à
l'autre et qui prétend sur les plongeurs
en saturation elles sont des plongeurs
professionnels bord des conditions mais
la plupart les gens vont plonger
peut-être 20 25 30 plongée par année de
45 minutes chacune dans des eaux
relativement tempéré la longévité d'un
plongeur je vous dirais un des plus bel
exemple il ya quelques années avec l'eau
jesse lee qui était un ancien de
l'équipe de cousteau et ces dernières
plongent il avait 82 ans
alors c'est ce qu'on est un petit peu
moins alerte parfois à cet âge là mais
il faut pas oublier que la plongée
sous-marine aussi et d'extrêmement
salvateur pour beaucoup d'handicapés ils
lorsqu'ils tombent dans l'eau laisse
complètement
enter sont complètement libérée du poids
de leur corps et je peux parler avec
nombreux d'entre eux notamment ceux
réunis dernièrement où il ya un énorme
loeb et c'est incroyable de voir
pour moi la plongée sous-marine lui a
des effets sur la santé mais comme
n'importe quelle activité sportive il ya
des effets extrêmement positif parfois
les effets négatifs
en même temps il faut minimalement être
un petit peu en forme pour faire
l'activité de sportifs comme celle là
excellent alors si la régie à d'autres
questions elle pourra vous les posez or
donc pas de problème merci beaucoup
nathalie lasselin de vous est joint à
nous aujourd'hui vous avoir parlé de ce
qui est tout proche et qu'on connaît mal
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci merci
alors nathalie lasselin qui est
exploratrice une plongeur professionnel
voilà je vais me tourner davout c'est
pas fini on appris du jouet en somme
c'est le deuxième tour de la grosse
boule cette semaine donc qui a perdu des
points vous avez perdu vais les prévenir
bull sur saint lô premier jeu vous fait
tourner la tête
on regarde et puis vraiment à toutes ces
boules intacte c'est important est bien
chanceux fric
ben j'ai demandé à une boule carrée mais
il dit ça se fait pas encore j'attends
comme la quadrature du cercle
alors voici deuxième tour la grosse
boule
on a tous entendu parler du naufrage du
titanic en 1912 n'est ce pas non loin de
terre-neuve l'histoire du naufrage de
l'empress au val'rhonne dans le fleuve
saint laurent
ça c'était en 1914 il ya eu aussi la
tragédie du loup citania torpillé par un
sous marin allemand
on est en terrain connu aussi d'accord
pour ceux qui connaissent bien le pays
maintenant voici la question quel est
donc parmi ces trois naufrages le pire
reste qui manque un naufrage flore parlé
avec stéphane alors naufrage la pire
tragédie maritime canadienne vous avez à
le lucie scianna en 1915 b le 1912 le
titanic ou c'est l'impression verlaine
en 1914 quand on parle de la pire
tragédie c'est le nombre de morts le
plus de gens qui sont morts alors est ce
que la bonne réponse et a b ou c
on va commencer par matthew
je dirais la réponse b b titanic le
titanic en 1912 bcc le naufrage le
prince charles en 1981 canadienne
c'est pour ça que je vous pose la
question a vu d'abord parce que je sais
qu'il a toujours là ouais ouais effet
avoir parce que on était en ou
internationale oui le a et b ses eaux
internationales le 1915 le site yana
puis une petite annexe du site web
musique ania merci beaucoup
alors c'est normal il sait quand ils
appellent ça lui une initiation qui a
pas de plumes du goudron l'armée parce
que j'ai gagné avec les vertus de mort 1
son nom de marne a écouté un nombre de
morges et les chiffres ce n'est que 1504
lusitanien très bien 1200 victimes
et puis le mp sauvageonne en territoire
canadien mille personnes 400 et 50
quelques ont survécu je vais vous
montrer les images à quoi ça ressemble
présentement cette épave pour parler
correctement
ouais c'est ça c'est quelque part dans
l'oeuf la seule race vous avez une idée
ou raymond exactement où dans le face à
laurence moreau il ya beaucoup de bruit
mais évidemment pour près de l'île verte
quelque chose du roi c'est pas
nécessairement à côté là alors j'ai ça
s'est passé et coûté 1 14 en 14 minutes
le il a sombré
c'est un paquebot il y en avait deux du
même genre ça y sont ils arrivent
souvent jumeaux le
construit par je pense une compagnie
anglaise ça se passe donc après la
tragédie du titanic et ils ont leurs
torts en plein brouillard
c'est pas eux qui ont été c'est un autre
navire qui est un navire je pense qu'ils
contenaient du minerai quelque chose
comme ça qui a un vraquier me vraquier
qui a heurté comme ça et tout le monde a
coulé rapidement
heureusement il y avait au moins deux
navires qui se trouvait à proximité dont
un qui a tout fait pour sauver la 450
passagers qui ont survécu grosse
histoire à l'époque mais qui a été
oublié c'est un peu comme une histoire
de naufrage qui comment dire est qu'ils
qui est plongé dans le cas plongé dans
l'inconnu
parce que quelque deux mois plus tard
c'était le déclenchement de la seconde
première guerre mondiale a alors
retourné oublier ça mais ça va ça aurait
pu voilà ces images tournées en 1917 par
une équipe qui n'est pas de radio canada
donc voilà je vous le mentionnez pour
ceux qui s'y intéressent
s'il ya un bien un petit musée pointe au
père c'est moi quelque chose dit ouais
où ils ont fait une illusion une
exposition ça s'est passé pas loin de
pointe au père je connais pas beaucoup
de repères j'ai jamais été là alors at
the door ce que j'ai lu dans ce que j'ai
vu une exposition qui est permanente à
cet endroit là attendez voir je vais
vous parler d'autre chose
je connais mieux la région des grands
lacs au canada où j'ai vécu une partie
de ma vie
il ya combien de grands lacs 5 parfait
peinture pauvres et pour des frais
question cinqui est un des clips de ses
plus grands lacs s'appelle le plus grand
des plus grandes plus profond c'est de
lac-supérieur ouais donc c'est là que ça
s'est passé je vous dis pas que l'année
passée la question troisième jeu vous
avez déjà perdu 50 boul
oui il a choisi bull cinquante autres
boules à perdre pour ce troisième jeu
d'accord c'est vraiment ce que c'est
mais vous regagnerez pas vos boules vous
avez perdu n'en voulait perdre essayé de
joindre itx
on affiche donc ce que je peux faire
c'est vous montrer les images d'abord du
naufrage du mv gerols connaît tous je
vous dis on va regarder ça ensemble
c'est des images est aussi une belle
chanson bien connue par beaucoup de
canadiens foot
exactement alors d'abord ça se produit
donc au niveau du grand lac supérieur en
mode novembre et à ce moment-là bon
c'est l'hiver début d'hiver vous voyez
leproux oui ça c'est la quille
cette émission est la timonerie en avant
ça c'est les bateaux typiques des grands
lacs qu'on voit passer ici qui ne sont
pas des transatlantiques ce sont des
lacs et à cause des types de vagues
qu'on a ici et le bateau à d'arriver à
la tempête et il a été coupé en deux il
ya une grande enquête pour savoir qu'est
ce qui s'était passé comme ça c'est le
foot qui chantent
ouais on va monter le son un peu une
chanson connue par tous les canadiens
cet ex plus tôt
comme partout
d
comme trouver
brett hawke un peu resté au
connu encore bien vivant aujourd'hui
continue à se produire sur scène donc
sacha je vais vous donner sa chanson est
sortie en 1916 -16 1976
voici la troisième question pour notre
grosse boule aujourd'hui en quelle année
le ssn manifester at il sombré corps et
biens
au cours d'une tempête sur le lac
supérieur alors raymond je sais pas si
on va vous donner le droit de participer
voici la réponse à 1969 b 1973 c'est
mathieu j'aurais tendance à dire réponse
b 1973 en plein milieu encore une fois 9
la régie dit quoi la régie dit c'est
ouais parce que la régie à la réponse à
la question elle sait on va afficher la
réponse c'est la bonne réponse
ouais c'est et c'est vrai c'est le
tromper vous êtes trompés 50 boules de
moi et puis vous aussi ah ouais je suis
triste et je suis étonnée vous vous
soyez tromper franchement ça me dépasse
bien sûr pourquoi 1969 parce que les
images étaient vieilles c'est ça je me
souvenais de l'événement weems banques
est-ce qu'il a sorti pour l'anniversaire
l'anniversaire je sais pas si c'est
comme ça il ya pris un arrêté beaucoup
de gens se soient sa première fois que
ça nous arrive à un énorme bateau
invincible un peu comme un titanic sur
le sur les grands lacs qui sort avec sa
cargaison de de minerais dans l'accord
et bien
c'est un lac tellement profond aussi
exactement on a du mal à croire qu'il y
aurait des tempêtes aussi violente qui
arriverait à couper un bâton de ces
comme sur l'océan y'a pas différent
cette fois que la tempête se lève c'est
la tempête c'est là où au canada les
tempêtes l'hiver prennent forme celles
qui arriveront qui vont un sommet l'est
du pays quand on va avoir des rangs des
grands lacs quoi c'est là que ça se
passe
c'est ailleurs au pays en alberta au
manitoba c'est une autre histoire les
tempêtes de l'océan enfin c'est
différent comme scénario mais au canada
dans l'est c'est là où elles prennent
forme
c'est alors les météorologues sont
toujours à l'affût de ce qui va se
passer au niveau de ces deux saisons
d'humidité très forte quand vous êtes à
windsor en ontario même l'été là c'est
très humide pas loin des grands lacs
s'est placé désagréable bon il vécut
boucher à toronto makam traoré très
lourd je disais par contre quand je
partais de chez moi j'allais au bord du
lac ontario
j'ai corrigé le parallélisme de mes yeux
en regardant l'horizon dit-il will dana
une mère tu es vraiment magistrat là où
c'est quelque chose en avions aussi un
regard noir où il a l'impression que
vous allez au dessus d'une mère vous
avez fait le voyage est volé entre
toronto et montréal
oui dans un petit avion du coup on
n'était pas une haute altitude et
j'avais une vue sur une partie du lac
ontario 6 1 mais à un moment quand on
ose tout mon impression qu on est
littéralement au dessus d'une mère c'est
tellement grand et moi je suis
originaire d'europe et en europe on l'a
on a très peu de laque aussi grand et
majeur quand on passe au dessus enfin
dans mon expérience où on a on a
l'impression que c'est la mer ouais il
ya la mer baltique la mer baltique en
europe je pense qu'il est apte aux
majestueuses mais ça reste une mère il
ya pas deux lacs
je pense qu'on a de quoi écouter
j'aimerais maintenant vous mettre en
valeur j'ai quelque chose pour vous yano
ce qu'on appelle un de rémission ya père
ya rien à perdre
en fait pas un métro on appelle ça
l'image la semaine il faut deviner c'est
quoi l'image la semaine et je vous
promets sol et des choses à dire au
dessus
alors s'il voyeuse jus d'ananas un
avantage comme au golf
parfait alors de dit moi je répond par
oui ou par non c'est tout quelle est
cette semaine en images la semaine
c'était en amérique du nord
attendez que je réfléchisse un peu eux
ouais en amérique du nord
ce que c'est mais c'est clair c'est
mondiale est-ce que c'est au canada ou
plus mais c'est plus haut c'est plus au
canada beaucoup plus aucun n'a pas
tellement aux états unis est ce que
c'est c'est passionnant seulement et du
canada le 1er juillet comme non non non
se dépasser allez-y est ce que b est ce
que ça s'est passé récemment ben ça a
été annoncé récemment
je reste un événement politique non
sociale culturelle environnementale de
façon distante la l'environnement oui
oui oui mais pas tout à fait ceux liés à
la technologie
ah oui ok c'est un topo que mathieu a
fait cette semaine c'est une découverte
spatiale
ah oui que c'est oui c'est la réponse
c'est quoi cette découverte là c'est une
découverte majeure au niveau spatial
c'est à dire que pendant des décennies
canton d'analysé l'espace on se basait
sur le système solaire
ok et du coup on prenait andreessen
solaire la de type de planète les
gazeuses et les rocheuses que qui ont
des nerfs plus des termes plus
scientifique et du coup on s'est dit
mais dans le reste de l'hiver c'est
qu'il y en a que deux c'est ça mais ils
savaient qu'ils allaient 80% des
planètes de l'univers qui elle était
différente qui était une forme en plus
petit entre les deux et on avait rêvé
pas savoir ce que c'est et du coup une
étude qui a duré cinq ans avec le le
chercheur principal et de l'université
de montréal a enfin au pu observer une
de ces planètes de plus près björn benny
qu'est exactement bien becker qui a pu
via les les télescopes satellite
je sais pas si vous savez il ya des
dents on a des satellites dont le
satellite hubble qui est un télescope
énorme mais qui nous mènent observer des
dés et où enfin des étoiles et des
planètes des distances
extrêmement loin oui et là on a
découvert il a découvert j'arrête le
suspense que c'est des crocs des
planètes qui sont entre les deux du coup
elle s'appelle sur terre ou sous neptune
yens parce que son antre la taille de
neptune et la taille de la terre
elles sont le coeur rose et l'atmosphère
c'est dégueulasse mais dégage pas de
l'oxygène à ces dégâts hydrogène
méthodes et ils viennent de le
professeur m'expliquer que c'est
vraiment une découverte
on vient enfin de trouver cette
troisième catégorie qui est la troisième
catégorie de planètes compenser qui
n'existe pas on manque d'image la
semaine pour confirmer et c'est l'image
d'ailleurs vous avez capté pour votre
reportage et votre entrevue vous avez
réalisé à on voit elle est très proche
de son soleil pour vous dire son orbite
c'est-à-dire un an correspond à trois
jours où l'on sait à quel point les
proches de son soleil et la spécificité
comme l'exemple qu'imad que m'a donnée
le professeur donné que c'est c'est
comme si on étudiait les humains qu'on
avait 400 milles humain quand on prenait
un seul et qu'on disait ils seront tous
comme lui
et en fait on a fait ça pendant des
années et là enfin on vient de mettre le
doigt sur ces planètes et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que celle-ci ya pas de
vide sûr parce qu'elle est trop proche
d'un soleil fait cinq mille degrés mais
lui son équipe cherche de la vie dans
l'espace et ses planètes qu'on appelle
exoplanètes parce qu'elles sont en
dehors du système solaire pourrait
abriter de la vision du coup ils vont
maintenant chercher à en observer qu'ils
sont plus éloignés du sceau du leur
soleil mais qui sont des types ni
neptunia littéraire là mais avec voilà
donc je résume cd planète sous marines
et ça soulève signait à l'assumer et
unième quoique neptune c'est ouais bah
oui voilà mais s'il arrive à trouver la
planète à la bonne distance comme et la
terre peut-être qu'il y aura de la vie
dessus et ça vous intéresse vous
personnellement oui pas juste
professionnel
j'aime beaucoup les tout ce qui est
actualité spatiale et le le docteur est
très positif en dix ans ici même 10 15
ans quand on aura du coup des meilleurs
satellite télescope dans l'espace
on pourra peut-être trouver des formes
de vie
moi je sais où se trouve la planète plus
proches sous marine mais je l'annoncent
à personne parce que j'y tiens c'est mon
endroit pour prendre ma retraite et des
histoires de québécois là qu'ils ont et
qui vit qui avaient un projet de
retraite de construire une maison dans
une zone qui maintenant est déclaré
comme étant inondable inondable ouais ça
c'est dans les journaux aujourd'hui ça
aussi ça la pub d'image la semaine
c'était riverains quand on met de
l'argent que voter brahma des années
puis on s'aime on se fait dire ben non
là vous pourrez peut-être pas parce que
les pas ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
il faut s'adapter au changement
climatique ça fait partie on en a parlé
durant notre émission la curieuse je
pense que il ya dix ans on n'en ferait
pas deux fois dans une même émission
mais là on est comme ces incontournables
on va ce qu'on va aller à la recherche
d'une nouvelle planète fut évidemment ça
c'est un débat qui est compliqué mais
vous déjà prendre soin de la note bref
exactement à écouter merci beaucoup
d'être là cette semaine c'est même si
bon j'arrête
alors on n'appelle pas quels sont les
scores l'important c'était très bien que
ça merci à vous deux et puis l émission
de tam-tam canada va faire relâche cet
été autour jusque à mon retour je pas
pourquoi c'est comme ça mais c'est une
bonne décision pour toutes les langues
on va faire un petit à petit une petite
pause et on revient vers le début du
mois deux ou est ce sera annoncé sur
notre nous pattano plateforme web que ce
soit facebook ou encore sur rci net.com
si stéphane parent on vous retrouve dans
quelques semaines on voit avant tout
avoir
[Musique]